what's your type of thicker i like first
off i just i like i like
i think women are cool so you know what
i mean you don't get it yeah you play
churches but i like i like
i like beautiful women these are all
women are perfectly beautiful
i guess i can't talk too much about
plastic surgery because i have braces
you know i mean that's kind of still
kind of
no it's cosmetic but it's not possible
but yeah yeah i know but that's like i'm
just not a fan of plastic i mean if you
want to do this cool
you know but like i mean just you wanna
are you like all natural i do like
natural
but not like supernatural girls here we
like right here
i don't i don't think i think fake
breasts are like
i think they're just you know i don't
[ __ ] with them you know what i mean it's
like listen
they just i don't like them that much
okay i don't like them that much you
ever felt like a brazilian
butt lift well you like listen i don't
like fake booties i feel like fake
booties
are like vegan cheese right now yeah
like you know how like
you know like when when people first got
getting fake boobs like it looked like
they inhaled two basketballs you know
yeah yeah it's like this is clearly fake
right now with them technology
yeah you can you can fit a two by four
in between right yeah and then it went
from
like you don't know now yeah the fake
boot is just like we
you look like you and smuggled two kids
you know what i mean like it just look
it's so fake it looked like it's not as
good
so i feel like all natural as well yeah
yeah yeah i like fake boobs and fake
booties in like 15 years because then
they'll catch up
and then you're not gonna know you know
what i mean but right now if i could
tell it's just kind of
it's like what's going to tell you fake
boobs but keep doing your thing like if
you're hey
keep doing your thing man like a lot of
women watch this yeah yeah i
i actually i still think you're
beautiful the way you are we had a we
had a poll yesterday you know who uh
summer
is summer rae yeah
so yesterday we had a poll going on
because we were trying to debate whether
summer
rae which is like an instagram model
fitness girl is better than megan fox
in her transformers we put up photos
on our instagram poll and megan fox won
no look it again look at it like
transformers
as far as fine like transformer like
she's better than megaphone yes thank
you
yes you're saying yes oh yeah i'm saying
that look at that body look at that
picture hey you're the only two i said
making fun oh okay
bro are you crazy she's still fine bruh
she's fine are you sick i'm not saying
she's not she's not making fox [ __ ]
she's not good
megan fox lips alone can you please what
are you talking about
another one with her okay come on come
on
can we slow down a little bit now go
powder now go where should i know the
butt hold up
hey hey come on bro come on
speak
a little bit with your mouse no no to
the right to the right bam click on
this look on it that's a funny video
that's a funny issue
she's still looking i still don't think
oh no you know what
not great there malik oh she's doing
like 14 minutes what are you talking
about
what okay wow
why are y'all even making this a
conversation bro megan fox [ __ ] it's
not close bro oh wait wait wait wait
look at this she just naked bruh look at
this
listen i don't care she's naked bro you
she naked she go
[Applause]
yeah exactly i'm thinking oh i'm
thinking of uh
i'm thinking a different what's the
other what's the black chick oh you're
talking about jordan woods
you're thinking of uh stallion
oh yeah okay well give me my handshake
that's summery
[Applause]
she ain't naked like first off the most
attractive
women are like don't try yeah well i'm
saying the ones that don't try yes but
like instagram models are
are just they're just fine i mean but
there's too many of them it's like
everybody finds
yeah you know i mean everybody finds
someone you're not trying and you're
still fine
you know like i would never follow her
because she looks like she has like a
bunch of you know
she political morals and stuff but you
know i just she's like
she's i'm not yeah i'm trying to
understand that she'll let you stay this
is what i came for
we saw her at uh swingers the lights
were low and she still was glowing
that's like beautiful she hates me i
don't like her hair i think i'm saying
megan good look she can be
bald-headed you ever seen some girl and
they'd be like man you look good you
a lot of people can't pull off ball
headedness it's like no she just fine
yeah she can do what if you find you can
do whatever you want okay when she was
young she was a quick question
so megan good or lauren london oh man
stop don't do that yeah
lauren london is bad r.i.p she's so
scorches no megan fox then all right
no no no no no sorry no i'm sorry bro
i'm sorry man look at her there's gonna
be a lot of pepsi it's a lot of yeah
go down right here down here right there
that's the video before he died but look
look how beautiful she is
the most wonderful things about being a
mother is that when your kids get sick
you better know she's sick next two days
you get sick
yeah hey can we click on that video
again just one time just click on it
the same one yeah click on that does
that say 32 million views
yup okay what did what time about this
is literally the video
it was right before yeah so everyone
went everybody went to and just like
sent their condolences
heavy [ __ ] yeah how about that when i
get off stage at the lab factory
right away you go bro i figured out what
you look like i'm like what this is from
a bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son